over a thousand years ago the first
demon was created and with it from the
first blood demon art muzon's blood
demon art is called biokinesis and it
grants him powerful biokinetic abilities
using his blood demon art muzan can
change his facial features replicate and
move organs in his body create weapons
using his flesh and bones contort his
entire torso into a giant mouth or even
create flesh puppets that he can control
he can also split himself into hundreds
of pieces that can reattach themselves
and regenerate into his full body muzan
also has very unique anatomy which he
achieved by manipulating and altering
his body's characteristics possessing
the grand total of seven hearts and five
brains these extra organs are largely
responsible for the majority of his
abilities and his resistance to
decapitation by nature and swords
conversely should many of them be
destroyed simultaneously he would be
significantly weakened in combat muzan
usually shapes his arms into long
whip-like appendages and creates tubes
and whips made of bones and flesh from
his spine and legs upon being cornered
by the demon slayers and pinned by
tanjuro muzan in a panic made his flesh
swell to the point he resembled a
gigantic infant all in an attempt to
protect his main body from being burned
by the sun before we continue any
further we want to thank impact third
for sponsoring this video hong kai
impact third now brings the latest 5.5
versions to captains the most awesome
one in v 5.5 must be during doll who is
the first valkyrie to save black and
white forms just look at her costume and
you'll see instantly that she is a cruel
beauty the deeper meaning of the special
costume originates from her legendary
fate and if you'd like to know more
details come and find the answers in
hankai impact third especially designed
for durandal the new battle suit
paladinous equinox also comes with two
alternative forms knight and guardian
respectively the switch itself has skill
effects too it's like owning two battle
suits in addition to the new characters
and battle suits hunka impact third also
prepared four new outfits for two
valkyries what's more exciting if you
get one outfit you can unlock the other
one automatically since v 5.5 is
designed for celebrating the anniversary
of the global server logging in rewards
a fourth anniversary emblem not to
mention a variety of upgrade materials a
large sum of guards and crystals the
spring events also rewards a new s-rank
battle suit spina astera and an s-rank
battlesuit option download the game now
and redeem the gift code for 30 crystals
a bunch of asteroid and a herscher trial
card kyogai kyoga is the demon we've
seen pretty early in the show he's the
main antagonist during the suzumi
mansion arc and one of the demons with a
very unique blood demon art after he
kidnapped one of the three children
outside of suzuki mansion he was
challenged by two young demon slayers
tanjuro and dinosuke there we could see
kyoga's amazing blood demon art called
drumming kyoukai harbors six suzumi
drums embedded in different parts of his
body and each one of them when played
and acts a certain effect on his
surroundings for example when he taps
the drum on his right shoulder he causes
the room he is in to rotate to the right
the same goes for the drum on his left
shoulder the drum embedded in his
stomach releases a three-claw-like slash
attack and the drum on his back
teleports him or other people to another
room within his mansion also kyoga
himself is unaffected by the room
rotation caused by his drumming and
remains standing on the floor as if
nothing is happening no matter how much
the room spins overall kyogai is a very
powerful demon and his blood demon art
made him worthy of the title of lower
moon sex in the past rui rui is arguably
the most powerful demon we could see in
combat during season 1 of the show he
carried the title of lower moon 5 and
was the first real challenge for a
protagonist tanjiro putting him in a
near-death state the main source of his
strength comes from his threads and his
blood demon art called thread
manipulation ruby's blood demon arch
allows him to create thin threads and to
manipulate them however he pleases he
typically extends the threads from his
fingertips like a puppet master due to
his own body's durability the threads
where he manipulates are extremely
durable and sharp being capable of
cutting nietzsche and swords and
blocking strikes from them as well rui
can further amplify their strength and
durability by pumping his blood through
them giving them a blood red color rui
has displayed terrifying proficiency
utilizing his threads for combat
purposes making use of the environment
to spawn a barrage of striking attacks
or manifest unavoidable web techniques
to trap and slice his opponents into
pieces he was only stopped when both
tanjro and nezuko combine their power to
defeat him enmu enmu is the lower moon
one demon and the only lower moon demon
left alive after muzan kibutsuji decided
to disband the lower moons he left edmu
alive and tasked him with killing
tanjiro and moon invades the mugen train
where our trio is and that's where we
first saw his amazing blood demon art
edmu's blood demon art grants him the
ability to force anyone into a deep
sleep this state of sleep is however not
perfect as enemy carefully preferred to
stay away from demon slayers out of fear
that his presence could awake them
although he is far less cautious against
normal human targets and who's blood
demon art's second ability is inspired
to enter manipulate and control
someone's dreams when they are asleep
when using this technique his victims
experience joyous dreams normally suited
to each person individually he also
ensures that they are unable to tell the
difference from reality and thus are
rapidly seduced to embracing the utopian
visions that lay before them making it
far easier for enemies to manipulate
them just like he can bestow dreams enmu
is equally capable of forcing nightmares
which he uses both as a psychological
attack and a means of torture when
trapping someone inside their dreams he
makes the realm inside their minds this
realm however has clear limits with
borders allowing one to enter the
victim's subconscious where their
spiritual core resides should this core
be destroyed it effectively destroys the
target's mind leaving their body as an
empty shell allowing enmu to kill his
victims in their dreams genya the next
one on our list is actually a human yes
you've heard that right a human who can
use blood demon art kenya shinozugawa if
you are confused let us explain by
consuming the live flesh of a demon
genia can temporarily gain demonic
attributes from it depending on the
strength of the individual he could gain
regeneration and physical strength equal
to the strength of the demon he consumed
due to having eaten the flesh and cells
of at least two upper ranks kokoshibo
and tantengu genya has seemingly
developed his own blood demon art called
wooden flesh bullets after eating the
cells of upper rank 1 genya develops a
technique where he merges his
demon-transformed cells with his bullets
and gun when fired the direction and
velocity of the bullets can be freely
manipulated by genya and easily move
around obstructions as seen when his
bullets moved around kokushibo's sword
directly burying themselves into his
flesh once inside his target the bullets
can immediately grow into a gigantic
tree similar to the tree creatures of
upper rank 4's xohakuten form and then
entangle and wrap around the intended
target paralyzing them his blood demon
art gets stronger and more powerful with
each demon cell he eats so we can only
assume how powerful he would become if
he ate the cells from the demon king
himself muzan kibbutsuji i guess we will
never know nezuko comodo nezuko might
seem like an innocent young little girl
most of the time but when it comes to
combat she is an extremely powerful
demon with an exceptional blood demon
art nezuko's blood demon art called
pryokinesis is simply put amazing she
can create powerful demonic flames from
her own blood and the best thing is that
it doesn't affect her at all her flames
are very special as her pyrokinesis can
only injure demons while being
completely harmless to humans this was
best displayed during her fight against
rui it was also the first time we could
see her blood demon art in battle one of
the reasons that makes her blood demon
art so powerful is shown during her
fight with upper moon 6 daki where she
uses her flames to completely burn
ducky's entire body even preventing her
from regenerating her blood demon art
can also neutralize demon poisons as
shown when she burned off gyotaro's
poison to save sanja shira tengan uzui
and inosuke she also managed to light up
tanjore's sword in his fight against
hantengu which helped him to take
advantage in this fight kaigaku kagaku
is one of the youngest demons to join
the 12 kazuki not long ago he was
actually a human and a former demon
slayer training under jigoro kujima
being tortured by a former thunder
hashira kagaku mastered all the forms of
thunder breathing except the first one
complementing his breathing style
kagaku's blood demon art grants some
special electrokinetic abilities which
allow him to generate and to manipulate
black colored lightning and electricity
from his flesh and blood this
lightning-like blood demon art creates a
special effect that cracks and rents his
target's flesh while burning it greatly
augmenting the lethality and offensive
capabilities of his attacks kagaku uses
his blood demon art to great effect
utilizing lightning in conjunction with
his thunder breathing techniques to
enhance his range and speed which even
zenitsu has trouble keeping up with it
is implied that this blood demon art
helped make up for kagaku's own
inability to perform the most
fundamental technique of the thunder
breathing style thunderclap and flash
making him one of the most powerful
users of thunder breathing as he had
already mastered the other 5 standard
forms daki daki is the upper moon sex
demon and even though many people think
he shouldn't be an upper moon it's her
amazing and powerful blood demon art
that puts her above all lower moons
donkey's blood demon art allows her to
create flower patterned obi sashes from
her flesh many people didn't know this
but yes she actually makes it from her
own body as well as freely manipulating
them at will she often creates these
sashes from her back and retracts them
back into her body when not in use she
has also displayed the ability to exert
control over her obey from extremely far
distances her sashes are noted to be
soft like silk yet as sharp if not
sharper than most nichiren swords shown
on many occasions when she cut nezuko's
entire body into pieces during combat
daki uses her sashes to unleash
long-ranged interweaving attacks while
also being able to use it to form a
shield around her body if need be making
her blood demon art an extremely
effective blend of offense and defense
her sashes are so powerful that they
could repel into block attacks from
tenkan's explosives and slice up
buildings with ease furthermore they are
especially difficult to cut because of
their soft properties and can further
loosen by bending and weaving her sashes
have a unique property that allows her
to store objects usually human she wants
to eat she traps them inside by
transforming the objects she wishes into
two-dimensional flat versions of said
objects do you guys think donkey is
worth of an upper moon title let us know
in the comments guillotaro gyutaro is
the older brother of the previously
mentioned donkey and the real upper rank
sex he is the real deal and an extremely
powerful demon and his blood demon art
is one of the strongest in the series
gyotaro's blood demon art allows him to
manipulate his own body in various ways
it is implied that gyotaro doesn't run
out of blood due to his regenerative
abilities giving him a virtually
infinite source of blood to fuel his
techniques in combat he usually creates
barrages of solidified sickle-shaped
blood as sharp as blades that can travel
at immensely fast speeds he is capable
of freely manipulating these blood
slashes at will altering their movements
until they hit his opponent or shaping
them however he pleases kyotaro can use
his blood demon art tactically to create
inescapable attacks that can overwhelm
the likes of tengen and holds off the
combined efforts of tanjuro zenitsu and
donosuke moreover gyotar's blood slashes
appear to be extremely deadly as zanoski
noted that a single scratch from them
would be enough to kill him the blood he
manipulates is shown to be quite durable
as well since tanju deduced that his
sword would shatter if he took the
technique head-on without deflecting it
furthermore gyotaro can create a shield
of blood in the form of a dome which he
used to protect himself from a barrage
of kunai further exemplifying his
immense durability gyoko as upper rank 5
gyoko is more powerful than kyotaro and
daki and his blood demon art revolves
around his porcelain vases he can
presumably spawn them anywhere within
his vicinity and create multiple pots of
varying sizes at once gyoko first
displayed the ability to freely teleport
from one pot to another instantaneously
offsetting his lack of legs and allowing
him to travel far distances with minimal
effort as well as to evade attacks
easily a gyoko can also trap objects
such as people inside his pots if the
object he wishes to seal is too big the
pots can simply compress them to fit
inside the pots also seem to give goku
liberty of whatever is inside which he
uses to merge the sword smith together
in impossible ways at the beginning of
the swordsmith village arc gyoko spuns
numerous gigantic fish-like creatures to
terrorize the village and kill its
inhabitants they are unable to be killed
by regular means and only die when the
pots on their back are destroyed these
creatures all possess unique traits and
characteristics some have sharp claws
some of multiple humanoid legs or even
monstrous teeth they also seem to be
decently powerful as these creatures can
kill the demon slayers that were meant
to guard the village however their
strength still pales in comparison to
the hashera as mitsuri and muijiro
swiftly subdued these spawns with ease
lastly gyouko can manipulate and create
water from his porcelain vases which he
uses to suffocate his targets by
trapping them inside a solidified
version of the liquid han tengu
huntenku's blood demon art is based on
his ability to create clones rather than
for combat purposes his blood demon art
is called emotion manifestation and it
simply allows him to manifest his
emotions as powerful younger clones of
himself with their own unique
appearances personalities and abilities
these clones are personifications of a
certain emotion hentangu has felt before
and mainly displayed that emotion each
one is identified by a kanji tattoo on
their tongue labeling their core emotion
and tangu can control these clones
however he sees fit though he usually
lets them act of their own free will
this ability is activated when
hantengu's head is cut off where his
head and body turn into two separate
clones with those clones splitting into
two after they are decapitated however
they're at their strongest when there
are only four of them additionally his
clones will never die as long as the
main body is still alive making it
nearly impossible to fight and defeat on
tengo alone nakime while we are on the
topic of blood demon arts that are not
based on combat we have nakime and her
amazing infinity castle we already had a
glimpse of nakimu's infinity castle in
the anime when muzan decided to kill all
lower moon demons simply put nakime has
the ability to create a castle with
infinitely many rooms she also possesses
dominion over the space being able to
manipulate it and alter it at will by
simply strumming her viwa even though
she can use her abilities for combat in
some ways her main purpose is to trap
the demon slayers inside the castle
nakime can also spawn portals at any
location to transport people outside her
fortress or anywhere within it in the
form of tatami sliding doors she uses
her portals for offensive and defensive
purposes as well displayed when she
created the portal to negate mitsuri's
attack one of her main duties was to act
as a mode of transport for the other
upper ranks when they are sent on
missions and to presumably assist muzan
in moving around the country undetected
akkaza akaza is one of the fan favorites
he's the upper moon 3 demon that we got
to see during the moog and train arc
when he battled against and killed
flemishera run goku what makes akuza a
unique demon is that he always fights
completely barehanded considering that
he got to rank 3 of the upper moon
fighting only with his fists it's safe
to say that he is probably the most
powerful demon when it comes to
hand-to-hand combat his blood demon art
combined with his pure strength makes
him even more powerful akkas blood demon
art is called destructive death and it
takes the form of a martial art style
that combines shockwave-like attacks and
his soryu style he mastered when he was
human the shockwave's occasion
manipulates our blue in color and can
take on many forms he is capable of
generating them at will from any
distance and seemingly from any part of
his body in combat akuza uses his shock
waves to accompany his own punches and
kicks to amplify his destructive
capabilities making his attacks covered
in a faint blue light destructive death
similar to the sawyer style is a
bare-fisted martial art style that
utilizes both the user's arms and legs
to unleash swift and powerful strikes
that target an opponent's neck and
weapons this blood demon art combined
with his superhuman strength and speed
makes him a formidable opponents in both
close and ranged combat this technique
itself was enough to overwhelm and kill
one of the strongest teshiras and later
overpower tandro and giu at the same
time doma doma is definitely one of the
most interesting demons in demon's lair
his character and personality are unique
he is outwardly friendly possessing an
approachable and charismatic air and
describe to talk and act in a calm and
carefree manner but don't let the looks
fool you he is a very deadly demon who
possesses an incredible blood demon art
his blood demon art is called
cryokinesis and it's based around ice
and frost he has the ability to generate
ice and frost from his own flesh as well
as manipulate it into a powerful
attacking weapon additionally the ice
created from his blood demon art is
extremely lethal to those that inhale it
causing the cells of the victim's lungs
to die rendering them unable to breathe
normally it also nearly froze kanyo's
entire body after just coming into
contact with it he is very skilled in
using his blood demon art and we've seen
most of his techniques during the fight
against shinobu kaneo and dinosuke one
of his techniques is called crystalline
divine child where he creates miniature
ice replicas of himself to battle his
opponents he is shown to be capable of
creating up to six clones of himself at
once all possessing roughly the same
skill and proficiency as doma himself in
addition to being fully capable of using
any of his techniques albeit not to the
same extent as himself furthermore these
clones are able to record any
information they gather during his
battle and relay it to doma allowing him
to fight his opponents while already
knowing their abilities however one
drawback to this technique is that the
clones require concentration in order to
maintain their functionality as seen
when they disappeared when shinobi's
poisons started to take effect kokushibo
now onto one of the oldest demons in
existence the legendary swordsman
kokushibo he holds the title of upper
rank 1 and is by far the strongest demon
of the 12 kazuki he invented his own
breathing style called moon breathing
and used it in combination with his
blood demon art his blood demon art
allows him to create and manipulate
dozens of sharp blades shaped like
traditional crescent moons from his
flesh katana they're implied to be
created from his blood and can be either
a bright yellow or bright blue in color
these crescent moon blades are extremely
chaotic constantly changing in size
length and speed making kokoshiba's
attacks extremely unpredictable and
unreadable as they have no set pattern
this blood demon art greatly enhances
the power of his techniques making every
single one of his sword swings extremely
deadly and dangerous he also seems to be
capable of using his blood demon art as
long as his katana is unsheathed
allowing him to create crescent moon
blades even without swinging his sword
or unleashing a technique sonomy stated
that if not for his years of experience
in the field of demon hunting he
wouldn't have been able to defend
himself from kokoshibo's attacks
kokoshibo displayed the ability to
exponentially increase the range of his
sword slashes with his moon dragon ring
tail technique and shape his slashes
into a circular drill-like shape with
his moon through bamboo leaves technique
his blood demon art is definitely one of
the strongest to ever exist considering
he was able to hold off three hashera at
the same time don't forget to redeem the
hong kong impact third gift code to get
cool bonuses also click on this video
where we explain all breathing styles
and demon slayer